je t'ai pris un yaourt t'inquiète pas il
est fait avec du lait bio de violet non
non
est un
mec très drôle ce serait un peu banal ce
serait un peu bateau
parce que c'est des chaussures bateau
j'ai le droit de frapper sur les
le dernier
allez
[Musique]
non non non non
c'est pas moi
[Musique]
[Rires]
l'alcool c'est pas cool et ben alors
pourquoi il y a
moi je le vois moi je sais pas vous moi
je le vois
[Musique]
là je te fais une demande relou mais
juste pour mon plaisir perso est-ce que
tu peux me le faire là en plus on est
pris des bougies avec ton frère en plus
on fasse
bienvenue Bienvenue
Bigflo mon lit vous êtes vraiment moi je
vous aime beaucoup et surtout je
pourrais dire que vous êtes pour toute
la ville éternité légendaire
[Applaudissements]